sometimes it feels like the universe is
just messing with you I have up on
screen here a sequence of computations
and what I want you to notice is how the
sequence follows a very predictable if
random seeming pattern and how each
computation happens to equal Pi you
might think that this was a pattern that
would go on forever but it doesn't at
some point it stops and instead of
equaling Pi you get a value which is
just barely barely less than
pi and before you go thinking this is
the result of some numerical error maybe
because we're doing something with
floating Point arithmetic if you work
this out more precisely here is the
exact value of that last integral which
is a certain fraction of Pi where the
numerator and the denominator are absurd
they're both around 400 billion billion
billion